Guantanamo has been built on how to destroy a human being totally –
how to damage him mentally, physically, spiritually.
This is the story of 779 Muslim men and boys who were held at the Guantanamo Bay Detention Center
– and of them, the 40 who still remain there to this day.
9/11 was difficult for all of us, for all Americans.
But I think what the intervening 17 years now have shown is that
abandoning our long-standing legal systems and our values are not rewarding for us.
They don't strengthen national security.
In the 17 years since hundreds of noncitizen Muslim men and boys were sold into U.S. imprisonment,
kept without charge and tortured, there has yet to be any accountability – and any real justice.
We, the United States, have done such a good job of convincing our population and the entire world
that these men are terrorists that it is impossible for men to escape Guantanamo when they're released.
And that's their biggest complaint,
is that everybody thinks they're a terrorist.
I try so hard to act – to be – normal, but it is hard.
In order to understand how and why there are still men held without charge in Guantanamo,
we have start at the beginning of the long history the United States has in Guantanamo Bay.
In 1898, following the Spanish–American war, the United States took control of several territories previously controlled by Spain
– including 45 square miles of Guantanamo Bay, Cuba.
And even after Cuban independence,
the U.S. maintained control through leasing the land. And it became a naval base.
In 1991, during a coup d'etat in Haiti, refugees set out on makeshift rafts and boats to claim asylum in Florida.
But the U.S. had other plans for the Haitians.
President George H.W. Bush found that he couldn’t send them back home,
so the Coast Guard started rerouting the refugees to the Guantanamo Bay Naval Base.
In less than a year, nearly 37,000 people were living in tent cities ringed with barbed wire.
Back in the U.S., a district court judge condemned the conditions and ordered the camp closed
– a decision that was later reversed.
Shayana Kadidal of the Center for Constitutional Rights was at Yale Law School at the time
and was part of the group of professors and students that worked on the Haitian Guantanamo case.
So you have people who are not American citizens, these Haitian refugees, landing in a place that
technically is Cuban but in every other practical respect belongs to the United States of America.
And then the question is, do they have full asylum rights
under United States law? And maybe even a preliminary
question – do they have the right to even set foot in American federal courts
and make arguments about what rights they do have?
And it’s that line of questioning and that legal framework that forms the basis of how the U.S government
would treat detainees arrested during the so-called “War on Terror.”
Our war on terror begins with Al Qaeda,
but it does not end there.
On October 7, 2001, the United States invaded Afghanistan, in search of Osama bin Laden
and other Al Qaeda operatives believed to be behind the 9/11 attacks
and believed to be under the protection of the Taliban.
And there was a big push to capture anyone alleged to be an Al Qaeda operative,
as Alka Pradhan, a lawyer on the Guantanamo military commissions who represents several current and former detainees, explains.
What we actually did is we dropped flyers over the tribal areas
and the border areas between Pakistan and Afghanistan, saying, if you give us members of Al Qaeda,
we will pay you anywhere from – I think it was up to – $5,000. President Musharraf of Pakistan is on the record
as gloating about how much money the Pakistani government made
from turning over people to the United States, whom they just labeled as terrorists.
Pretty much anybody who is an Arab in Afghanistan after 9/11 was worth 20 years' salary
to hungry villagers, to corrupt warlords, to corrupt Pakistani policemen manning the border.
And so with bounties ranging from $3,000 to $25,000,
the United States begins piling up these men really quickly
– who are held without charge and without proof.
Many were picked up for just being at the wrong place at the wrong time, or even wearing the wrong kind of watch.
One of our counsel likes to say that being foreign in Afghanistan after 9/11 was like driving while black.
One example of this was Pradhan’s client Emad Hassan, a Yemeni student in Pakistan who, when he was sold,
was asked by U.S. military officials if he knew Al Qaeda, to which he responded “yes.”
And they said, OK, all right, well, you're coming with us. And he was sent to one of the camps, where he was just
brutally tortured. He was stripped naked, he was beaten, he was subjected to freezing temperatures.
And during this time, he was interrogated again and he was asked, do you know Al Qaeda?
And he at this point realized that perhaps there was some mix-up.
And it turns out that the Al-Qa’idah Hassan knew was a small village in Yemen.
Hassan, told he’d be let go, would remain in Guantanamo until 2015
– 13 years after he was sold to the U.S. military.
Now, with all these men who had been rounded up, they needed to be kept somewhere.
Having the detainees on U.S. soil was quickly discarded as an option,
since that would give them certain rights and privileges.
The thought process at that time that Rumsfeld and others at the Department of Defense are going through
is, “Where can we hold them where we don't have to apply U.S. law
– where we don't have to apply the Constitution but they are still going to be under our complete control?”
That brings us to Guantanamo Bay Naval Base.
The first detainees arrived there from Afghanistan and Pakistan in January 2002.
They get off the airplane and we have no idea who they are, where they're from, what they're alleged to have
done, anything like that. We, in some cases, don't even have names for them.
Despite not knowing much about who they had captured,
the U.S. government had to build a case against each individual.
They don't approach it as, “You're innocent until you're proven guilty.” They approach it as,
“These men are all enemies of the United States.” And so they start interrogating them.
Once [they] were brought to Guantanamo, [they] were chained in what we called stress positions,
which are essentially chained from their wrists, from the ceiling, or had their wrists and their ankles chained
together, or had dog collars placed around their necks and chained to the walls.
Some of them had those dog collars actually attached to leashes and
were then dragged around floors while being quote “interrogated.”
For Shaker Aamer, a British resident who spent 14 years in Guantanamo without charge,
there was something worse than the physical torture he endured.
Once you get beaten up, once you get hanged, once you get all these, whatever they call it, hog-tied
and all these things, pain, physical pain, then it goes away. But when they try to play with you mentally,
and psychologically, all kind of manipulation, you feel like every time they find something new.
As word started to leak about the conditions in Guantanamo, groups like
the Center for Constitutional Rights started to petition to have the detainees’ cases heard in federal courts.
To Kadidal’s surprise, they won the landmark case Rasul v. Bush:
We win the Supreme Court case in late June of 2004, and suddenly the government realizes that
it's going to have to go in and defend its detention of each one of these individuals in federal court.
So immediately they started having to pull together files on people.
Those “files” the government was putting together were the biographies that would come to define these men.
And they were based on evidence obtained from the so-called “enhanced interrogation techniques”
– which, by the way, is considered “coerced evidence” and is inadmissible under international law,
and even U.S. law.
The biographies were also based on information gathered by former detainees turned informants.
We know now from reporting in the Washington Post that there were individual detainees who got their own
separate housing, electronic sound systems and little TVs to watch movies on,
in exchange for informing on their fellow detainees.
Not only is this false evidence probably the most important evidence that the U.S has, according to Pradhan,
it’s also on the public record. The “biographies” were leaked by WikiLeaks
as part of the Guantanamo Files in 2011.
To this day, if you Google, you know, Emad Hassan or Abu Wa'el Dhiab or any of my former clients,
the first thing I think that comes up are these biographies, many of the facts in which
we proved to be false. They all sound very, very similar. It seems like every detainee at Guantanamo
was Osama bin Laden's brother-in-law and every detainee at Guantanamo
fought with bin Laden at Tora Bora.
And these false biographies continue to haunt them today, even after they’ve been released.
In total, the United States would come to imprison 779 detainees,
with 21 being children, under the age of 18 when they were caught – the youngest believed to be 13 years old.
Of those 779, to this day, 732 have been released – many of them many years after they were first detained,
and without a single charge having been brought against them.
The Bush administration oversaw the release of 532 detainees,
either back to their home countries or to another country willing to accept them.
And when Barack Obama was campaigning for the presidency in 2008, one of his major campaign promises
was to shut down Guantanamo.
We did see, when he came into office, within the first day, again,
we have that executive order that comes down to close Guantanamo Bay.
Guantanamo will be closed no later than one year from now.
Things go south very, very quickly.
Despite the Democrats having control of the House and Senate, the Obama administration didn’t follow through
on the promise of shutting down Guantanamo,
and didn’t even try to clear the names of all those wrongfully detained and tortured.
That’s what I find to be just absolutely unforgivable, is that we know all of this false information is there,
but President Obama will not stand up and say, “Hey, we got it wrong, these were all mistakes made.”
And solely because we were not willing to face up to our own mistakes as a country,
we continue to perpetrate torture at Guantanamo.
And that lack of reeducation and accountability has had an impact on the men who were released.
The same guard who will attack you and fight you and choke you,
the same guard, in another occasion, will pretend he’s your friend. You don’t know how to feel,
you don’t know the difference between hate and love, you don’t know. Really, you don’t know.
Your feelings is all jumbled together.
They can't get jobs, they can't get education. People won't befriend them.
Having detained these men for years upon years
– taken decades of their lives, taken them away from their families, mentally debilitated them, really
– and then release them to places where they don't know how to get by.
It's a human rights and humanitarian crisis of enormous, enormous order.
Today, 40 men remain in Guantanamo, with only 7 having been charged.
And even their charges depend on weak information and questionable links.
For Pradhan, who represents detainee Ammar al Baluchi, the nephew of alleged 9/11 mastermind
Khalid Sheikh Mohammed, the question of injustice faced by detainees past and present
is a question of injustice that impacts American citizens as well.
Americans should care about it, again, because it is so much more than just those 40 men.
Guantanamo is the root of all of the national security debates that we have now.
The utter disregard for people of color because they are people of color? That colors our debates on immigration,
on the refugee crisis, on prison reform here in the United States.
So Guantanamo really is sort of – and continues to be – the crucible where all of these violations really
were born, and they continue to spin out from Guantanamo.
It's sort of the crucible, the epicenter, of all of that.
Hey guys, thanks for watching.
Guantanamo is a really tough subject to tackle, and we only scratched the surface in our story.
Let us know in the comments what you think, and don't forget to like, share and follow.
And we'll see you next week.